pour faire connaissance mon cher jean
carmet je vais me permettre de te poser
quelques questions auxquelles je
souhaite que tu ne me répondent sans
fard
ton premier souvenir c'est quoi
ma première respiration peut-être hui on
dit que j'ai une grande mémoire tout le
monde disait dans mon enfance que j'irai
loin parce que je me souvenais de ta
première c'est ma première fugue c'est à
trois ou quatre ans où il ya plus
exactement c'était la recherche d'un
bruit de bruit d'un train qui passait à
par bull et moi comme j'habitais
bourgueil d'avoine passée par là et on
me raconter toujours les exploitent ce
train qui était le nôtre est hystérique
c'était un train cela veut dire que tu
mets beaucoup les trains et j'ai voulu
voir de près comment s'était fait alors
je me suis habillé puis je suis parti
j'ai fait trois kilomètres à pied on m'a
rattrapé au bout de trois kilomètres
c'était ma première fugue ta première
basse ma première baffe sa du cdu est
très jeune j'en ai pris beaucoup j'ai
été élevé à la barre m'enfin pas
cruellement mais la barse la baffe et la
pompe rilke août tombe dans le cul ça
j'ai connu beaucoup jusqu'à temps que je
cours plus vite que mon père son premier
rêve c'est mon premier rêve il a été
provoqué par un ami de mon père qui
s'appelait et mid est qui
rêver nous de nous faire faire un voyage
en amérique ray alors ils avaient
inventé pour nous un à une embarcation
qui était un fut coupée en deux auxquels
on avait mis une voile oui ça c'est cuit
mais il ya eu l'avion aussi et oui c'est
un avion qui faisait la vitrine pour les
fêtes de noël chez un marchand de
nouveautés de bourgueil et que
on vous avait donné à émuler à toi pour
l'équipe et du mètre 1 un moteur un
moteur avec un élastique qui vous
permettrait de traverser l'atlantique
son premier amour mais mes grands
parents avaient une petite maison à la
campagne près de tours où ils allaient
passer
les vacances l'été quand il faisait très
chaud à tour et il y avait un jardin
juste en face c'est nous il y avait des
émanations d'odeurs une odeur que je ne
connaissais pas parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de pieds de lavande à la maison et
cette odeur m'attirer et cette odeur
m'attire et si bien que je m'approchais
de cette maison et j'ai vu une
ravissante petite fille qui allait très
bien avec l'odeur de la lavande voilà
cette politique c'est très joli ça c'est
très poétique mais ya pas eu le choix
avec une charcutière non car la
charcutière de bourgueil je la regardais
d'abord parce que je l'avais une grande
admiration parce mag pour ce magasin
parce qu'il y avait une il y avait une
tenture à ce magasin quand pour cacher
les produits et pour éviter qu'ils font
à la chaleur et ça représentait qu'une
peinture à l'huile qui représentait une
chasse à courre ou une chasse au
sanglier d'aller admirer cette peinture
parce que c'était de la peinture à
l'huile et xav et une certaine
réputation et quand ça se lever il y
avait là la charcutière qui était très
belle très bien habillée maquillée
c'était la seule vraisemblablement il se
maquiller dans ce pays et elle avait un
une très très belle poitrine avec 1
une blouse amis d'années qui lui donne
une forme roussin moi qui n'avais aucune
idée de ce que c'était une paire de
seins à l'époque j'étais plus encore
fascinés par les saintes va ça requiert
que par la chasse au sanglier ta
première cuite vous savez que moi je
suis né dans un pays devint donc la
cuite c'est une chose je ne dirais pas
de c'est pas une chose obligatoire mais
le grand but c'était de
d'emmener un parisien dans les caves et
de le faire ressortir dans un état très
très très avancé elle m'est arrivé une
fois d'accompagner des parisiens avec
mon père il n'était pas surveillée j'ai
bu avec eux 1 j'ai bu comme eux et quand
je suis sorti de là j'étais cuit comme
les parisiens et mon père était fou de
rage et de honte parce qu'il a dit il ne
tiendra pas le co
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus